we've entered the eleventh hour of this
Greek crisis and we urge the Greek
government to do a deal before it's too
late we hope for the best but we now
must be prepared for the worst and in
the United Kingdom we've taken the
measures to increase our Economic
Security so we can deal with risks like
this from abroad and clearly now we must
go on and complete that plan yes p
preocupado creo que estamos en el
momento delicado el momento delicado
todo el mundo quiere llegar a un acuerdo
para las que si tienes the latvian
presidente has steered negotiations on
epsy regulation since the initial
tabling of the proposal in January up to
reaching political compromise it was
supported by the council and the
European Parliament will vote on it next
week the council attained general
approach on banking structural reforms
I'm pleased that ministers approve the
country specific recommendations
proposed by the commission on settings
of may the recommendations this year are
fewer and more focused at concentrating
on the important reforms that can be
implemented by member states over the
coming 12 to 18 months echofon also
discussed the action plan adopted by the
Commission on Wednesday to improve
corporate taxation in Europe making it
fair more efficient and more gross
friendly today echofon following the
european commission's recommendations
decided to abrogate malta and poland
from excessive deficit procedures we
also have had the adoption of the
council conclusions on capital markets
union it was very clear the conclusions
this has to be a project for all 28 and
I very much see it as a classic single
market project for all 28